[Music]
the new breath of the wild dlc includes
a bunch of new armors and masks but if
you can't be bothered searching for it
and would rather spend your time eating
a sandwich instead I've got you covered
let's start off with the masks the Korek
mask which will help you locate missing
quark seeds in the world is hidden in
the lost woods so teleport to the
woodland tower and enter the forest keep
following the torches until you reach
here and the chest should be hiding
right there and the Deku Tree is nearby
if you want to check out the trial of
the sword mode we actually have some
gameplay of that for you to check out
but for now let's keep going
majora's mask is next and it's sitting
pretty right at the Colome o garrison
ruins just north of the great plateau
glide-on over there
dig up the chest and enjoy your freaky
new masks and finally there's Midna x'
helmet which is hiding in the waters at
the sage temple warp to the nearby
shrine and jump down for the bridge to
get it get rid of these pesky enemies
surrounding you and claim the chest for
yourself there we go it'll probably help
your death perception a little bit but
hey looks cool oK we've got all the
masks now let's get some of that sweet
sweet phantom armor the pieces are all
fairly close to each other in Hyrule
Field so let's go get the helmet first
it's over in the Coliseum so if you
sneak around this lyonel right here I'm
sure he won't mind Oh God okay so the
trick is to be sneaky it's up against
the wall on the northwestern side and
there we go
the chest piece is over here at the
sacred ground ruins in front of the
castle ignore the Guardian and grab the
chest sitting in the water oh baby this
is definitely how the armor should be
worn and the Phantom Greaves are over at
the Hyrule garrison ruins take out any
pesky enemies nearby and the pants are
all yours
all right now it's time for the good
stuff the tingle outfit the shirt is
located in the town prison to the west
of the castle and an another Guardian
all right let's take care of this guy
there we go tingle shirt right here the
tinkle hood is here in the exchange
ruins being guarded by this annoying
Yaga but this is your tingle armor so
blow up and take the chest
and finally the piece de resistance the
tingle tights to acquire this a lovely
pair of pants go to the may village
ruins put that Guardian out of his
misery dig up the chest and enjoy the
silky smooth feeling of the tingle
tights there's still a lot more out
there with the new breath of the wild
DLC pack including the hard mode the
hero's path and the travel medallion
somewhere out in the world so keep your
tinkle tuner sets a game spot and
subscribe for more breath of the wild
videos
[Music]